welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 23 and
we're going to learn how you can
market your company like a billionaire
enjoy
[Music]
how aside from making great products how
do you get people
excited about tesla there's a lot of
people i know and that i talk to who are
just
intrigued and interested and excited
about tesla as a company
the thing i really focus on at tesla is
like we
really put all the money into an
attention to trying to make the product
as compelling as possible
so um because i think that really the
way to
um sell any product is through word of
mouth so if if
one somebody gets the car they really
like it they and
and actually the key is like to have a
product that people love
um and and generally people
you know if they're a party or touring
friends or whatever
um you'll talk about the things that you
love but
you know if you just like something it's
okay you're not gonna care that much but
if you like reactions
you're going to talk you know and and
then that'll generate work during word
of mouth
and that's basically how how our sales
have have grown like we don't we're not
spending money on advertising or
endorsements or
and so anyone like buys our car they
just bought it because they they like
the car
and you know it's like it's genuine you
got to differentiate yourself i always
ask myself
why am i different how am i different
and i think it's very important to be
i call them the three c's but clear
concise and confident
you have to be able to describe it in a
minute or less make it so clear the
customer really wants to make smart
decisions
and they really want us to make it easy
for them so i always say
make somebody feel the pain or if it's
not the pain
which means the problem on why you did
what you did or why you're creating what
you create
then explain to them your uniqueness and
then right after that you've got to give
them the solution
very quickly and then take it through
and say why you're the best i mean very
quickly
explain to them in just a few seconds
why you're the best option
and i find that very very helpful so in
everything i do i ask myself why am i
different
i always ask everybody in the company to
think outside of the box to be very
innovative
i like to stop people and say if nobody
showed you how to do your job
how would you be doing your job just sit
with that thought
and i'm basically a case study of
someone who did not know
how it was supposed to be done i mean no
one had shown me i'd never taken a
business class
so i i find there's so much
amazing you know creativity that will
surface if you stop and get off the
autopilot that we're all on
everybody's doing something because
somebody else showed us how to do it but
if you really want to create
big change in the world or in your life
it's going to happen when you do it
differently
or you take a risk to do it different
than how the 50 people or 100 or
thousand people before you did it so
really encouraging thinking that way
with inside the company and as we grow
still remaining entrepreneurial
having fun i would say i've always
believed that a strong mission
statement's really important
and i have to say we've never succeeded
at it it's like this odd thing
you know we've had them every year for
15 years and they're constantly
different and
now we're also cynical we're like come
on we're trying to make people happy i
mean that's the fundamental thing is
in consumer service you know we're
trying to be better and
and us in disney and mission aren't that
different there's a bunch of different
tactics at it
um but we're an emotional product we
cater to the things that are important
but not necessary
um and i love that part about it because
like when you're selling
milk or penicillin you're selling
something somebody needs
and we get to sell something you want
okay that you choose to do
because it's really cool a human you
know to
uh be entertained and connect to people
over entertainment
and so we celebrate that a lot and we
want to change the industry but in terms
of
like a mission statement like so many
companies have
you know facebook talks about a more
connected and open world
um and then you see that phrase again
and again and again and it's a powerful
mantra
we don't have an equivalent and i think
we probably would have been stronger if
we do
in the early days um it was uh
to connect people with movies they'll
love
and it's okay but it's kind of like the
long kind of awkward phrase connect
people with movies that love and you
know it's just not punchy
and um and then so like we used it we
had t-shirts you know
and then it didn't really motivate
anyone didn't really stick um but we
knew we were trying to make people happy
with dvds and then eventually was
streaming and original content
so it didn't hold us back much the
swoosh
the very famous nike swoosh how much you
pay for that
design there was a graphic art student
at portland state that had done some
work for us and
she charged two dollars an hour and we
said how about coming up with a
with a logo for the shoe and she spent
17 and a half hours on it so it cost us
35 dollars
but and as i said it's easily worth it
it's turned out to be
fairly iconic but when we went public
in 1980 we gave her 500 shares of stock
which she still owns she's never sold a
share
and that's worth a million dollars now
too so good for her yeah so good so it
came out
so story had a happy ending i know
nothing about technology i know nothing
but marketing i know nothing about
illegal
all the stuff what do you know i don't
know about people
i know people i was trained to be a
teacher
as a teacher you want your students
better than you are
you want you want your best product is
your students
you want this student to be a lawyer
that's stupid of a banker that's to be
the entrepreneur that is a is a
mayor you don't want don't want this
bankrupt that in the jail that is in
trouble
so you always want people better and
then you have to listen to them you want
to see that
and then make the all the things to
making sure that you can empower them
you can make them cheap teamwork you can
then collaborate
so this is how we do and i find the more
you care about your team
the team will care about you and the
team will care about their customers
so i talk to all of my people early days
don't make me happy
don't love me make your customer happy
make your customer love you and i will
love you any minute
that is very simple so everything we do
as a founder
make your customer happy get your team
make your team happy
and you will be happy there's this
inherent conflict in the system though
which is
you know are we trying to optimize news
feed to give each person
all of you guys the best experience when
you're reading or are we trying to help
businesses
just reach as many people as possible
and in every decision that we make
we optimize for the first for making it
so that when
for the the people who we serve who use
facebook and who are reading news feed
um get the very best experience that
they can and that means that
if a business is sharing content that's
going to be useful for them then
we'll show that but that means that if
the business is sharing content that
isn't going to be useful for them
um we may not show that because it's
probably more important that they
learned about their friend who had a
baby and their baby is healthy
so that's an important guiding principle
for how we think about this stuff
and as the um and as the products
continue to develop there's just going
to be
more people sharing more things and
we're going to continue to try to do our
best at
showing the best things that we can
understanding that there's no way that
we can
that a person will ever take the time to
go through every one of the 1500 things
that are shared with them every single
day um so that's
but that's kind of how i think about
organic reach and um
you know there are a lot of pages that
are going that are doing quite
successfully and their organic reach is
growing quite a bit because
they're delivering content to people
that they really want um so if you're a
business owner and you're thinking about
how to use
your free page on facebook i would just
focus on trying to publish really good
content that's going to be compelling to
your customers and the people who are
following you
the students around me were really
important as well right and
um both in high school
and in college i mean the people who
started facebook with me and a lot of
people who are still with me running the
company today
are people who i met when i was at
harvard and um some of them were my tfs
at harvard
right and you know when the professors
were off writing papers
um these were the people who actually
taught me and then we hung out and we
had like social bonds and
academic bonds and i just i wouldn't
understate the importance of that and i
mean it's very tied into
my whole philosophy and the product that
i spend my life building facebook
because
um we just believe that social bonds are
critical and um
and one way that i think about the the
value that facebook is filling in the
world is that you know you go through
school
and at least when i did people just
focused on
you know academics like achievement
different areas and
one of the things that no one really
ever taught me was like having friends
is really valuable
no not that i didn't have friends but
but like um
although you know the movie yeah um
but that first girlfriend but for sure i
don't think anyone is like
it's not like okay third grade we're
gonna like now we're gonna like teach
you
that like hanging out with people is a
very important development
right and i don't know i actually think
that that is and um
i think that's part of the reason why
sometimes people view facebook as a
waste of time but i actually think it's
this extremely socially valuable utility
and
i know that i wouldn't be where i where
i am today without
that aspect of my life being as
developed as the academic part
the idea that you could get people to
to decide to support this foreign aid
thing which is a big deal
for our foundation from a numeric point
of view we're still
pushing that a little bit but honestly
the story of the one child
you know if you say to an audience
here's the picture of the child shall we
save this child
they're more engaged than if you said
hey let's save a million children
you know so there's definitely a sort of
you know 10 to the sixth
problem uh here somewhere
humans are not wired uh
to be to do that on a numeric basis
um and so you know that's why we have
people like bono
and and many others who come from a more
storytelling
world and then they let me throw a few
charts and numbers in
uh because i think uh that
that should should be there once your
heart tells you what direction to go in
to prove that this is a a very
affordable
not you know not a big deal well-managed
path to
to be on how would you define your
strengths and your weaknesses
how you can you know incorporate those
into a team kind of aspect
well i'm not somebody who knows a lot
about marketing
you know i wouldn't enjoy being a
salesman for a position where you're
actually
creating the products and thinking
through what those features should be
i'm fascinated by that i've followed the
history
of the industry read about the mistakes
that have been made
so product definition product creation
very strong
if you have a team that understands the
customers the sales the marketing i'm
not going to bring that but i
i would enjoy working with them the
beauty of my life
edward is that from i'd say
32 33 on i figured out
how to be myself completely on
television
and all these years i have
made a fortune really being myself so
i'm never not
me i'm never not the person that you see
you know there are days when i am
more open and warm than others and one
of the things that actually caused me
in 1991 to get my own
plane i was in the airport and i was
just minding my own business
and a woman came up and she said you're
not acting like you do on tv
oh and i said what's that she says well
on tv you're hugging everybody and
you're just sitting here and you're not
hugging away
i'm just sitting here man i'm just
waiting on the plane so
um if i'm in an airport i'm not
necessarily walking around hugging
people okay
but i am i am just always just myself
we pull up the 20 hosts and search
results and we realize something
that the photography the images of their
listings
are actually not very good so we kind of
have this realization you know
we can solve that problem we know how to
take a good photo
but it's not scalable that's the thing
is that up until this point
we had tried to solve problems in a
scalable way which i think
i would call like some of the mythology
of silicon valley is that
you have to solve problems in a scalable
way that one line of code
has to meet the needs of hundreds tens
tens of thousands or hundreds thousands
maybe millions of people so paul graham
comes along and basically gives us this
message
which was the single greatest piece of
advice we ever got go
meet your people do things that don't
scale
it'll teach you you'll learn from it so
we fly to new york that weekend
we rent a camera with a wide angle lens
and we go from door to door
throughout manhattan and brooklyn so
here we are
in the environment of our customers
now watching them use our product in
real time
and we're seeing a lot of things that we
didn't know
were problems we got so close that we
got to step into their shoes for a
moment
and see the world through their eyes and
really
see the pain points that they were
feeling and that to me is like
that's the basics of innovation you take
an enlightened empathetic point of view
for your customers
you combine it with your own unique
point of view of the world
to create something new you know what
happened because of this
they started using the word love in the
same sentence as airbnb
they started telling their neighbors
their friends their family members their
co-workers
and so two things started to happen
simultaneously the amount of choice
started to go up and the quality of that
choice went up as well
and when a new host came to the site
they said oh well i guess i need to have
really nice photos to be in the part of
this marketplace
and we started to see the number of
reservations go up who here likes to go
to the movies
okay who's seen star wars wait who
hasn't seen star wars
okay we have to talk um so
i found the original script from star
wars this is an image of the script
um this is where movies start they start
in written form and sequence so how do
they get from this
to a cinematic 4d experience
what's the bridge that the storytelling
industry has been using for the last
85 years to get from the written
sequence of words to a cinematic 4d
experience
storyboards storyboards
bringing words to life storyboards show
you
things that words can't
and they help bridge words to experience
so everyday airbnb we face the same
challenge
right we there's experiences happening
people are checking into tree houses
people are cooking and sharing food with
guests from around the world
and they're even housing each other
after hurricanes
so how do we bridge from our script
to these real world experiences
we storyboard and we storyboard like
crazy
last year we embarked on an ambitious
project to map the entire guest
and host journey on airbnb and we did it
through illustration
we looked at the key emotional moments
of the journey
and we drew them we visualized them
and what it's done for us it's allowed
our entire company to achieve a new
level of empathy
with our customers these are all the
storyboards back in the office
it's allowed us to align around a common
vision
we gave it a good go right from 01 to 08
we
trusted it back up but it was they they
did slip on a big banana peel purple and
yellow banana peel for yahoo for you
that know their colors
that was another thing so we
we sell to them right and our office is
in dallas
and the way we ran our business it was
just like lean and mean right
you invest in your product you invest in
your customers you invest in your people
and you know we had open offices you
don't need fancy stuff
they immediately came down and just
redid
all the furniture in purple and gold i'm
like it's cool that's my high school's
colors
you know but why are we spending this
money got a whole new office a whole new
building
you know i'm just like why are we
spending this money one of the things in
my rules right when i look at companies
to invest in
if someone walks in with swag here's my
coffee mug with my logo
here's your t-shirt with my logo i don't
see anybody wearing a t-shirt with a
startups logo do you
no would you wear some other startups
logo polo shirt
hell no hell no right
it's just a waste of money you know put
your money where
you're able to differentiate yourself
and add value
that separates yourself so you can get
ahead don't waste it
your take is essentially that sure you
can put together something cheap off the
shelf but that's
that's not necessarily good enough for
what we're really going to need to make
this work
yeah yeah absolutely and um you know
if you if you want to talk about just
you know cheap for example from a lidar
standpoint you know you you could go
down to
you know to best buy here and buy a 50
solid state lidar that sees out to 200
meters
it's it's a golf range finder that tells
you how far away a flag is
you know but uh you know the reality is
that that's that's something that well
it sounds really good in theory is like
completely not applicable to autonomous
vehicles and i think that that's really
the
challenge with these these systems that
you know while we've seen
you know a new trend to be able to
reduce the cost of these devices
we've actually seen the performance
proportionately be reduced along with
the cost
which actually doesn't really get us
anywhere the whole point is we needed
orders of magnitude better performance
from the start
if we want to be able to get from these
autonomous test fleets from where we're
at now that
um need constant human oversight and
takeovers to
being able to get something that is
truly autonomous uh at the same
time though obviously it does ultimately
need to be cost effective uh
you know and that's that's why you know
uh we actually
we did a uh an announcement just uh a
couple of weeks ago here about
how we've been able to make this
receiver system in our in our lidar that
a lot of people traditionally assume
would be very expensive really cheap
uh or we made it really cheap and only
use one laser and one receiver in the
product as opposed to you know
um what would traditionally require you
know like 64 lasers and 64 receivers
so gotten the cost and complexity down
dramatically which is critical
long term um you know ultimately the cos
the cost near term is
isn't as big of a deal you know for uh
for autonomous tests and development
fleets but
it's it's important that things scale
long uh from that standpoint but also
you can't sacrifice the performance to
be able to get there you have to do both
one of the key i run a marketing agency
and a lot of my customers say well
i spent one dollar and i one pound and i
only got one pound back that's not
success i need to spend one pound and
get six back what is success in
marketing
number one is to get known you shouldn't
advertise first you should get known
first
so if i spend a dollar in marketing or
branding
i don't need my dollar back it's when
you have a toilet you buy a business and
you get a
hey we should put a bathroom in our
business how many of you have a bathroom
at your business
what's the roi on that
there's no roi on that
how many of you have an air conditioner
and a heater at your company
what's the roi i mean does that get you
customers the air conditioned sends you
customers
some things you need to do because
you're in business
when did you start making sense and not
getting known
there is nothing more important than
getting known
if you if you can't get known you can't
be in business
if i don't know you i will not do
business with you
if i don't know this woman in red no
matter what
no matter what no matter how good her
product is or what the price is
i will not do business with her
regardless of her ethics
regardless of her honesty regardless of
her service
if if we if we don't know each other
we won't do business so i would spend
money on marketing before i'd spend it
on a toilet and air conditioning
and climb online stand is just through
there
and to the left i mean i would
and i wouldn't expect i wouldn't expect
mark to get me a lead i would expect
mark to get me known
so that when people see my name they're
like
i saw you do this thing with
with grant cardone when he came through
wales that's how you lift
your brand it's just a smarter thing to
do today
so that when you advertise with him and
you see the name
now you're like oh i remember you from
this and that and they put the pieces
together
people buy from people they know not
from people they trust
people do not buy the best product
either people buy the best known
product i love that you can't tell me
this is the best coffee in the world
it's the best known coffee in the world
i want to talk to you about marketing
i've learned a little something in the
last 12 years
since we started first started a youtube
channel but even over the last 30 years
when i'm trying to get myself
known as a kid that you know was
starting a business and i had an idea
and i was going out knocking door to
door
cold calling on companies and my pitch
was always hey my name's grant cardone
and i got an idea
and it took me you know from 35 i'm
sorry from 30 years old till
45 years old nobody knew me one door at
a time
it was slow and go it was very very
painful
if you don't like the idea knocking on
doors and taking 20 years for people to
get to know you well
i'm going to show you in this video and
i'm going to show you in this video how
you can actually get
known blast out to the world if you have
an idea
a product a service an event a charity
you want to get known you got a book you
want to sell you got a product you want
to sell you want to do it from home
online people ask me all the time hey
grant if you were 20 years old what
would you do today
i'd do two things i'd get a mentor and i
would market online
okay i'd take all the money that i make
it online the third thing i would do is
i'd invest in real estate
and you see me doing that every day but
today what i want to talk to you about
is marketing
how can you get known in the world today
you might not know this but last year in
2019 forbes magazine
called me the number one social media
influencer in the world to watch
okay what they didn't tell you was i
raised more money last year than any
other single
human being in the world i crowdfunded
360 million dollars in the last 25
months with almost
no ad budget now you're going to say
what about kylie jenner and what about
the soccer pro look i'm not a celebrity
i'm not an actor i'm not an actress i'm
not running around in a bikini
i don't have any athletic skills i'm not
floyd mayweather i'm not kevin hart i'm
not a celeb like i'm not well
known by the world yet i raised one
third
of a billion dollars a third of a
billion dollars no endorsements
that third of a billion dollars bought
one billion dollars worth of real estate
in addition to that almost every month
last year we did
four million dollars a month
in educational products and services
sold online i don't think i'm
exaggerating by a penny that's a million
dollars a week
now if you'd have told me when i was 30
years old that one day i would be
i would be uh making a million dollars a
week i'd be like are you stupid that's
ridiculous okay i spent
15 years 15 years knocking on doors
traveling all across the united states
put three million miles on my body
my on my body flying across the united
states
spending 200 up to 250 days a year
trying to get people to know me
one door at a time you don't have to do
that today youtube facebook
instagram tick tock linkedin twitter are
ways for you to get to know today so
what i want to start with is
okay i want to start with well who are
you okay who are you exactly
what have you done or accomplished what
have you accomplished
okay what have you failed at
okay what is the story you're gonna tell
and basically it goes like this okay you
basically
draw yourself out who are you okay
who are you what have you accomplished
what have you failed at
what do you do every day because what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
build the story
that you're gonna tell every day on
these channels okay now every day you
see me go
post something online
you see me post a lot of stuff okay in
the beginning people were just accusing
me oh you post
every day he's posting something okay
whatever
look you cannot you can you can
criticize me
uh forbes magazine acknowledged me
but they didn't acknowledge me for the
thing that's most important okay whether
i'm the number one social media
influencer in the world or not i don't
think that even has anything to do with
anything
because it doesn't feed my kids the fact
that i raised 360 million dollars
and did 55 million dollars in online
educational sales last year
and sold out a 12 800 person event in
las vegas
some of the tickets were 20 grand a pop
the fact that i sell corporate contracts
30 to 60 thousand dollars to fortune 100
companies
every single day of the year online
using social media marketing
that's important that's way more
important than who's the best social
media marketer in the world you got to
pay your bills
okay i want to show you how to monetize
your brand your name
your company your services your idea and
your products
so look this is you okay this is me
this is you okay you take a whiteboard
like this and you draw out who you are
now what i want you to do is i want you
to start writing out
who are you this is how you're going to
tell your story many of you
many of you maybe maybe you've had this
problem what is your content
what are you going to talk about what is
your program what is your package
don't figure out the content first what
i want you to figure out first what i
want you to figure out first i'm looking
at my watch because i'm a father
i got two kids see if you just look
around and pay attention to what you're
doing right now
i tell my wife this all the time look
don't try to create ideas
what are you doing that's valuable
everybody everybody is doing something
that's valuable
if you are without work today you don't
have a job you're 18 years old in an
inner city
baltimore and you're thinking about
going out tonight
you don't know what to do don't know how
to make money don't know how to take
care of your mom you got a drug problem
all those things are your story
okay those are your story don't look for
ideas
don't look for lyrics don't think about
the lyrics you have the lyrics inside of
you
so just like you would just like a
rapper would build a story out of their
experiences
you know if you listen to kanye in the
early days he's talking about when he
worked at gap
he's talking about when he ripped off
the register he's talking about when he
stole
when when his manager uh thought he was
stealing from the store because those
things happened to him too many of you
are trying to create products and
services
what does the customer need i'm going to
find out what
problems the world is having and i'm
going to solve them dude if you figure
out the problems you're having
figure out the problems you're having
which needs to be another list right
here your story
comes from your problems
okay so look let's just take this who am
i oh i'm grant cardone
okay that's my name well you can only
go okay grant cardone okay
now later what happened because i
started telling my story enough i became
somebody other than grant cardone okay
over the
last 12 years it's only been 12 years
since i started on the multimedia
did i say to multimedia see okay then i
became mr 10x
and then i became uncle g and then i
became master g
these are nicknames that people gave me
okay these are stories that you get to
tell
how did i become uncle g because one day
i told a story
about how i was 15 and 16 and 17 years
old
and i wanted an uncle to help me and
they never came and that
i told my mom one day i'm gonna be an
uncle to others
i'm gonna be the uncle to others that my
uncle wasn't to me
and somebody started calling me uncle g
right see again it comes out of stories
who are you who are you okay i'm gonna
give you this assignment to sit down and
start looking at
who are you oh i'm a college grad
i graduated from college
okay who else oh i'm a father so what i
want you to do is
everything i'm a father i'm a husband
okay this list is going to get real big
i'm a business owner
anything to do with business owner oh i
survived 2008
huge part of my story by the way i saw i
resolved at 2008 with no bankruptcy
all my friends went bankrupt that's part
of my story this is going to be the
content
oh i'm a real estate investor
okay now i'm a cat daddy which by the
way i'm not
proud of i'd much rather be tiger king
okay okay so i'm a real estate investor
all right oh i have 1.8 billion dollars
worth of real estate
a lot of you out there you're like oh
he's always bragging he's always
bragging look if you're not telling your
story if you're not bragging about your
story
you're not telling your story jc
is going to tell people until people
finally say it about him
that he's the jay-z okay one day you're
going to be able to walk in a room and
you will not have to introduce yourself
the whole room will get
sucked out the the energy in the room
will get sucked out because everybody
will do this
oh he's here look who's here
that's what this is about it's about
marketing yourself until the world knows
you
to the point you don't have to introduce
yourself i didn't know this when i was
25 years old 30 years old 35
40 years old 45 years old you know what
i was doing
hey my name is grant cardone hey my name
is grant cardone today i can get in a
room i don't have to introduce myself
every day
until you work yourself up the food
chain okay
so if i want to call and talk to floyd
mayweather today
the first time i might have to introduce
myself i'm probably going to need his
agent i'm probably going to need a
friend i'm probably gonna need somebody
that works for him but at some point
floyd is gonna be like oh now i know who
you are you're that dude i see you all
over i saw you at the game i saw you
here i saw you there i saw you online i
saw you on youtube
i saw you talking about you know
whatever on tv the other day okay
okay so business owner 2008 survivor
i'm just giving you ideas right here a
billion dollars in real estate oh
let's take the other side okay
accomplishments failures
your failures are part of your story
okay drug addict
okay lost my dad
uh lost a brother
uh what else uh failures uh terrible
student in school
this becomes part of your story it
becomes part of what you're gonna post
online
is part of the the energy that you have
to share with your audience
that you can communicate with somebody
at eight o'clock in the morning again at
9 30 again at 11
again at one and you can mix it up okay
so
uh let's see here i got uh these are all
things that that i'm building
storylines about that i'll be able to
share with my staff
okay oh wow i'm a marketing guy
i'm i'm sitting here talking to you
about marketing
oh i'm a speaker you see i actually have
to have people remind me
what i do i've only done like 7 000
speaking engagements and i forgot
that i'm a speaker in fact i'm probably
one of the highest paid speakers in the
world today am i bragging
you know what they say if it's true it
ain't bragging
or maybe it's both and by the way if
you're going to market yourself you're
going to have to brag a little bit
because if i don't tell people maybe you
don't know hell i forgot i was a speaker
and by the way speaker in dubai speaker
in singapore
a speaker in australia
all across the world 19 countries last
year so i can now start communicating
with other people in other parts of the
world
and telling people in australia yeah i
was in sydney
i was in melbourne i was in brisbane by
the way i went to auckland then i went
to fiji
i can't wait to come back i'm marketing
directly to that group of people
okay so oh reminds me three
million miles
with the airlines commercial flights
in coach seats middle seats earning
miles
eating cold nuts
putting up with flight attendants
telling me to put my phone up
oh just remembered i'm the guy that got
your phone
approved on the airline so that you can
actually use your phone on takeoff
that's in the newspaper okay where i
fought the faa
and what's that got to do with anything
because you know what when the airlines
get going again
i can communicate about what's going on
with the airlines it's again part of my
story you'll use it oh just forgot
how about i'm the only guy in the world
that has ever
uh huh no no only guy in the world
that's ever
videoed a bird strike
the only guy okay i forgot but it's part
of my story it's some content i'm not
saying it's going to be a program you're
not going to have a program
on bird strikes probably not okay but
look how well
tiger king did a story
okay oh i wrote books okay
accomplishments we're back to
accomplishments now
okay they'll just pop up okay author
arthur what okay eight books
13 best-selling business programs
now what is the business program most
people don't talk about their business
programs
i've made more money from business
programs than i have
from my book sales i'm one of the number
one
most listened to programs on all of
audible
with the 10x rule the 10x rule has been
translated hebrew
arabic portuguese
italiano 10x
10x your pasta connection mama
okay uh let's see author eight books 13
business pro
oh cardone university almost forgot only
50
million users
now you're gonna start you're not you
might not have all this stuff
if you dig in you will you'll have as
many things as i have
i bought a house before accomplishment
uh i got a divorce
in 72 hours most people don't even know
that story about me
friday afternoon realized i was going to
get a divorce on monday morning it was
finalized
it was a saturday a sunday two of the
days the lawyers weren't even open
on monday at 10 a.m it was signed okay
my entire divorce cost me eleven hundred
dollars
who's done that nobody can do that okay
would you say jared crowdfunded i
crowdfunded
the first reg a fund ever
to 50 million dollars okay probably in
the last 24 months i think with great
certainty actually using facebook and
instagram have crowdfunded more money
than any other single living human being
which would include dead people too
oh who sold out marlin stadium i did
okay
oh i forgot i was a car salesman
what a story car salesman
sells out marlin stadium uh
marlin stadium right here see see one
thing will start leading me
oh huh i'm a watch collector jared's
having to help me again okay
okay you've seen videos on all this
stuff by the way oh i own a jet i forgot
i forgot i'm the guy that bought the jet
when there wasn't a jet for sale
also i'm the guy that never got on a jet
until i was 28 years old
part of the story also i'm a guy that
never flew on a private jet
until i was on my own private jet never
charted it yet never been on a jet
until i stepped foot on a jet that i
bought
all part of the story right so is
aviation a group of people
sure are car salesmen a group of people
sure
have i worked in other retail industries
yes i was a furniture salesman
when i was uh 17 years old i worked at
mcdonald's
when i was 16 years old i was fired from
seven jobs seven jobs
in a row
i was a shoe salesman maybe you maybe
you heard the story of me and kevin hart
talking about selling shoes i think
kevin could have outsold me on shoes
okay okay
but i had a different reason to be there
okay i was fired fired from seven jobs
let me clean that up
okay so what do i have it one two three
four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve huh i'm a
teacher
every day i'm teaching i'm a coach
how many people have i mentored jared
tens of thousands tens of thou and look
look i had to write all this stuff down
and forgot that i was a coach
the point i'm trying to make to you
until you do this white board and do it
over and over again i've done this
probably six or eight times in my life
you gotta keep doing it over and over
and over again i'm a friend
okay i'm a hard friend
i'm a hard friend okay
i'm not a friendly friend oh i forgot
brand
clearly i have a very distinct brand
not just one brand either okay if you
notice if you look at that board
i've been branded car salesman i have
been branded social media influencer
i have been branded real estate investor
i know some people that know that i'm a
real estate investor that don't even
know i'm on social media
i know people that know i'm on social
media talking about x y or z maybe money
i'm a money guy i talk about money all
the time
oh philanthropists forgot i've raised
110
million dollars for charities in
addition that giving 10
away for myself raised a million dollars
for the grant cardone foundation which
helps kids
uh without fathers
we did that in one event in las vegas
employer i'm actually an employer
business partner okay i'm an employer of
over 500 people i'm a business partner
i got partners that have made more money
with me than they could make on their
own
you know who i'm talking about
uh let's see oh backgammon
i play backgammon it's another thing so
again this is your story you got to know
it man if you're unconscious about who
you are
if you don't tell your story nobody's
going to tell
your story for you this is where the
books are going to come from this is
where the audio programs come from this
is where the speaking gig come from
this is where time on stage comes from
this is why you can wind me up
drop me on a stage anywhere in the world
and say talk
and i can be like okay what we're going
to talk about
a podcast have i done a few podcasts not
even on the list
okay in fact i have probably made more
money doing webinars than any other
person
alive today i just want to give a big
shout out to my friend lewis house who
taught me how to do podcasts he taught
me him and
webinars podcast webinars yeah i'm not a
podcaster
webinar see i don't even know what to
call them okay
now if i was joe rogan i'd be a
podcaster but
i'm not i did a podcast i did one
podcast
in two hours we did almost two million
dollars
took us less than 21 days to promote it
um 80 000 people registered
how do you do that you got to have
stories to tell we did an event once
i forgot live events we do the largest
live events
on planet earth i know i'm giving you
guys
a lot to listen to right here
oh forgot i did a tv show okay i forgot
to
i'm i've been interviewed by multiple tv
shows fox
cnbc yahoo
uh cnn okay
so now the question is going to be how
do i put all this together so it's not
just
mumbo jumbo you can't read it anymore
and this is how this information sits in
most people's head it's just a
bunch of mush it's kind of like looking
at the riots on tv
is that a macy's
you know is that a macy's is that
bloomingdale's is that nike's
okay i think i saw a bunch of you
actually robbing some of those stores
okay let me tell you who you're really
robbing by not doing this you're robbing
yourself
you have to get your story clear you got
to get your story clear
arnold schwarzenegger very clear what
his story is
know exactly who the dude is the rock
very clear on what his story was it's 7
to 12 bucks seven dollars it's over and
over he tells a story seven dollars
the rock here hey the rock here dwayne
johnson tried that and went back to
dwayne
the ron johnson he tried to abandon that
rock thing dude it cost him
okay who is he who are you what's your
story
what are you going to be known for
what's the rock known for
wrestler funny man
tough guy uh movie star
fitness guy tequila guy see the story
starts building out right
he comes from being the hawaiian simone
i don't know oh yeah i forgot louisiana
i'm a southern boy
i am entitled to abuse
the english language see i just lean
into it
samoan samoyen whatever
dude i'm from louisiana okay lean into
it
okay i misspelled words walmart
uh dude own it
own own it own who you are there's no
power
in you trying to deny where you came
from and what your story is
your story is money somebody is going to
relate
to your story the first book i ever
wrote
first of all it took me 51 years to
write the book do i have that in common
with other people
do you think you need to wait until
you're old to write a book
no you're not you don't okay so when you
start telling your story
when you start when you spend time with
me in this mentoring group
what you're gonna do is get clear on
your story
see today with social media what happens
is people are trying to be me
or they're trying to be gary vee or
they're trying to be
um i was watching a movie the other
night i'm like that guy's trying to be
tom cruise
like the the guy the actor had not
figured his
own self out yet so he's pretending to
be someone else rather than himself
until you find out who you are and learn
how to tell your story comfortably in
your own shoes
uh drew brees drew brees yesterday came
out and said man i'm never not going to
defend the flag
okay all of new orleans went freaking
nuts on him he came out today and said
man i apologize i realized i heard a lot
of people
because of my he he leaned into his
story
social media is a distribution network
it's free okay it is
probably the greatest gift whoa
what what whoa okay oh yeah let me write
that mechanically
deficient igmaranus
oh yeah i cuss too and i'm a redneck and
i shoot guns
see see all those things are part of the
story i gave a dog
an enema once with a hose with a garden
hose cut off the end of it only a
redneck does that how you know you're a
redneck
when you cut off the tip of a a garden
hose
you turn on the faucet and you put it up
the dogs
to get the peanuts out of them that he
ate too many of that's
how you know you a redneck
okay and by the way it was the perfect
cure
so so a dog owner you see all this
talking i've been doing what 20 minutes
and i forgot man i've owned dogs i owned
a dog called
a beagle when i was a little kid i lost
him i owned another dog called [ __ ]
he was a found dog he was you know we
called him [ __ ] because
he was a mutt right i owned a doberman
pinscher i owned
uh uh two great danes and two chocolate
labs that were flown in from whales they
were exceptional phenomenal dogs i owned
a pair at once
now i got two cats so why do i want to
why do i want to tell that why do i want
to know that i've owned animals
because about 40 of all americans have a
pet
okay in fact some of you will pay more
for your pet than you will your
girlfriend or your boyfriend
you'll leave them before you leave your
little ooh
okay you'll pick up their poop but won't
pick up my
clothes okay so check it out check it
out this
this is this is what we do this is how
we lay out our opt-ins
so when we start telling stories see
we'll start having people opt-in to
grant cardone.com forward slash mentor
okay then we'll have a thank you page to
respond to
offer a buy or a no buy i'll be going
over all this okay the exact funnel that
we lay out
okay one of the things that we do here
probably better than anybody in the
world i mean i'm just telling you
we don't sell funnels don't have a
funnel business to sell you
but what matters more than the funnel
itself is what you're saying
while you're communicating through the
funnel what am i saying
am i doing video am i doing text message
am i doing
chat am i intervening am i using a
landing page am i doing a website
that's what we're laying out here is it
a one click upsell
we we ran a program this weekend it was
free 70 000 people registered
how do you get people to even register
what are you going to pay for that okay
how are you going to make sense of
whether to continue with it or not
continue with it
when they pay for it do you make money
we had 70 000 people we were profitable
before i did the event it was free event
we made 250 000 in less than 21 days
and were profitable before they did the
event our last 10x growth conference
we had 12 800 people show up for this
event might not seem like a big deal to
you
we are the only profitable event
business in the world today
we make our events profitable the moment
you walk
into a 10x growth conference you can
look around and you can tell
these people already made money i know
all of you have been to an event before
where they weren't making money
they didn't make money they lost money
to get you to the event and then they
spent the next two or three days selling
you something hard
they probably used me as a headliner
maybe tony okay maybe pitbull
they bring in these headliners so
sylvester stallone was there and you
went in there and then they
then they gotta they gotta make it up
later okay on our events what we do is
we flip the model
i'm not gonna go into everything here
i'll be doing that on our mentor call
but this is basically laid out how we
can be profitable how you could be
profitable
before you even literally
you could make money on your ads
not on your event
and so you'd quit complaining about the
cost of advertising because you'd be
like
okay we spent a dollar and made six
bucks we spent 20 days and made 250.
what was the product uh we hadn't
delivered one yet
wouldn't that be nice we made 250 000
and then we turned the webinar on on a
saturday afternoon and made another 1.7
million dollars in
two and a half hours some of those
people by the way when they click from
zero then they went to ten dollars
then they came to the webinar
immediately went to ten thousand
ten thousand in the first 20 minutes
okay in the first 20 minutes of this
webinar and i'll show you how to do this
in our mentor program in our marketing
mentor program
in the first 20 minutes of the program
we had already done
80 000 a third of what we had advertised
for 21 days
and had another 180 000 and people that
wanted to spend more time with me not
less than that was in the first 20
minutes
the first 20 minutes we almost did what
we did in 21 days
and then went on to do it on the million
seven but you just need to know what is
the funnel when i come to a one click
upsell for real estate master class at
97
where do i go from there is it up is it
down
or is it just all around do i do this on
youtube do i do it on linkedin do i do
it on instagram do i do it on facebook
where do i push to is it an email
program how many emails we send out last
year
200 million 200 million emails how many
people are on an email list
so 1.3 million people first you got to
build a list
i started with one email it was mine
okay
it was gc grant cardone.com you can try
it right now
it's the oldest email i have started
with grant gc i'd email myself
how does this look i do it all the time
how does this email look
i look at ads all the time ad copies how
does this ad look and i send it to
myself
i write it and then send it to myself
and i look at it
see as a creator you want to you want to
believe it's
oh [ __ ] was good or maybe you don't
believe it was good and that's not
so good don't decide if it's good or not
good
send it to yourself and then look at it
okay 200
200 million emails that you can learn
from me
what worked what font worked
what length of email worked what are we
saying in the subject line that worked
do the words all need to be spelled
right should there be images should
there be video should there be links
should we send a landing page
should we send to a website wouldn't you
like to know all this i'm telling you
you can sit
at home today you don't have to go back
to college you don't even have to finish
high school
and you could make a you could make more
money than your mom and dad combined
sitting in front of a computer or with a
telephone
if you had the right product the right
service the right price point what is
the right price point
okay and if you started zero then where
4.95
4.95 cents 10
19 when do you get 100 when do you go to
a thousand should you go to ten thousand
could you get to a million dollars how
much we raised today
four hundred twenty thousand dollars
came in online today crowdfunding
using instagram facebook youtube now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
making a product that people love starts
with you making something that you
love really think about it would you buy
from you
would you subscribe to you would you
comment and tell your friends
about you in our rush to get rich to
make money
we push products out that we don't love
and if you don't love them
people around you won't love them either
so look at my youtube channel as an
example
i love my youtube channel i make my
youtube channel
for myself i learn it's selfish it's for
me
the top 10 rules videos the espresso
videos the content that i bring together
i need it it's my education i love my
channel i would share my channel with
other people
if i saw my channel and i wasn't
creating it'd be the first thing that i
subscribed to
it would be much watch youtube for me i
need it
and if you guys didn't like it i would
still create it for myself i wouldn't
have as much editing and fancy effects
and all that stuff but i would still do
it
because i need it for me i make it for
myself
selfishly and then i share it with you
guys and thankfully you guys like it
enough that
i can turn a business from it and
continue to hire team and create more
content and pump more stuff out but
as much as i think that my channel still
needs to get better and grow and improve
and
i still suck and i need to continuously
get better at the work that i do i think
my channel deserves a nobel peace prize
like
i think my channel is amazing
and you have to love what you do you
have to feel like
the thing that you're doing yes can
always get better
but it's really solving a problem your
product
your service what you create your
expertise
solves a problem you know that it's
genuinely helping people
if you don't have that belief you're
never going to win this is why so many
people
who are certain businesses when you go
and you look
at hot business trends for 2019 or 2020
or how to win in network marketing and
like what products i should sell
if that's how you're starting you're
gonna lose if you're just chasing trends
you will lose
there's nothing wrong with network
marketing per se just most of the people
getting into it are just trying to make
a buck
just like how most people get into
entrepreneurship you're just trying to
make money
too many people and then you end up
going broke because the people who love
doing that thing
will crush you every day of the week
think about who you're going up against
you're going up against people in
whatever industry you're in you're going
up against people
who have experience who have expertise
who have knowledge and
love the thing that they're doing and
you're gonna go in because it's a hot
trend for this year
and expect to win no now
if you love it and you absorb it and
it's
it's for you and it's must-have you will
pour so much energy so much love so much
creativity
and find a path nobody else has seen
before that's how you ultimately win
that's how you can then start talking
about it start promoting it start
building exposure getting word of mouth
if you want people to talk about you you
have to create something that is worth
talking about and there's no
way that you create it unless you
absolutely love the thing that you're
doing
so you have to create a product or
service that you would use yourself
you have to create a channel that you
would subscribe to yourself you have to
feel confident
that if your mom was suffering with a
problem that your business
could solve that you would recommend it
100
to your mom if my mom was struggling
with entrepreneurship you need to
subscribe to my
channel it will help you it will save
you
if you can't be like that yet go back
make it better
until you find something that you
absolutely love and pour your energy
into
so i'm going to give you a three-step
process that you can follow to help you
evaluate where you're at and how you can
get better
step number one get out of your space
wherever you are right now wherever
you're working
you're in front of your computer you're
at your office you're your home your
base
whatever wherever you normally work
wherever you are right now get out of
your space
just get out of your typical space go
outside for a walk
go down to the lobby cross the street
whatever get outside your typical space
okay step number two now that you're in
a different space think about your
customers
think about who you are helping think
about the problem that you solve
so if it's me i can go for a walk
outside i'm thinking about entrepreneurs
i'm getting out of my space it's too
easy to get locked into what
what i'm doing right i got to make i got
to make 20 videos today i got to respond
to comments
i got to connect with my team we gotta
learn all the stuff adds up and we
forget about our customers
so i go outside and think about
entrepreneurs
and i try to picture the people that
i've helped the people who come to my
workshops and people who ask me
questions and people would join me on
lives right
close your eyes you're in a new space
now and you think about your customers
think about the people who you help
the people that you are designing your
products and services for
think about them picture them try to
picture somebody right picture an
individual that you know that you are
trying to help
picture that person in your mind and if
you don't have a customer yet think
about the ideal customers that you're
trying to target and try to come up with
a face
somebody you can look at and then set
number three go back to where you were
go back to your office your computer
wherever you were
with that person in mind and then
evaluate your products
with that person in mind look at your
youtube videos look at your products
look at your services look at your
instagram feed whatever you're trying to
get out there look at your books
look at your books whatever you're
trying to promote
look at them with that person in mind
now you've stepped outside your
day-to-day
you're above you're not in the in the
muck of doing all the work i know you've
got tons of stuff to do you're an
entrepreneur i feel you
you've stepped outside you've imagined
that person you're coming back and
looking at your products or services
with fresh eyes with them
in mind do they actually need it
will this change their life will this
solve their problems
and if not go make it better if you want
to sign up for the entire billionaire
mindset series for free and get the
companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there